berkeley so
[Music]
hi hi everyone just i'll just share my
screen
can you see my screen
all right good um
all right so so uh i'll get started so
it's
great to be telling you about this work
at this reunion actually
um i think that it fits well because um
it is a result of a collaboration
that started during the quantum wave
semester last year
so i'm very thankful to my collaborators
james dakshita and fermi
basically you know after the pandemic
hit we started meeting every week
virtually so i've definitely learned a
lot from them
i can say this has been for me one of
the the bright spots during during this
pandemic
something that i look forward to every
week
i'm also actually thankful to simons for
the great idea of putting the lattices
program together with the uh
the quantum one in fact james takshita
and fermi were all
formerly participants in the lattices
program
and uh yeah so before starting i should
also say there is a concurrent and
independent work to ours which proves
the same result
with a bit different techniques by uh
alex who's here
uh rachel lin funsong and vinod by
kuntanatan which
i believe is also the result of a
collaboration that started
during during the semester assignments
so in this talk i'll be focusing on our
own work
as this is the one that i know best so
our work establishes that
one-way functions imply secure
multi-party computation in a quantum
world
so let me start by telling you what
secure multi-party computation is
so in this setting there are a number of
parties who can talk to each other
each with a private input x i
so the goal is for them to compute a
circuit c
on their joint inputs so c takes as
input x1 x2
x3 and x4 here and the parties are going
to do this computation by talking to
each other so by exchanging messages
and at the end of the protocol each
party should receive the output of the
circuit
on the joint inputs so this is the
correctness requirement
there's also a security requirement
which is the following an adversary who
corrupts
any subset of the parties should not be
able to learn anything about the honest
party inputs in this case here x1 and x4
beyond what it can anyways learn from
the output of the circuit
and so this is a very general primitive
with many applications
an example of a practical application
just to get an idea is you know you have
a set of hospitals with sensitive data
about their patients
who want to train some kind of
statistical model on the joint data
while maintaining the their own their
own patients data as private as possible
so you can do this with multi-party
computation
or mpc for sure and this is very well
studied in classical cryptography
and a lot of this study focuses actually
on a simpler
primitive which is known to imply mpc
and so this primitive is oblivious
transfer which is just a very special
case of multi-party computation
so in oblivious transfer there are only
two parties there's a sender
who has as input two strings as zero and
s1
and a receiver who just has this input a
bit b
so the two parties interact and at the
end of this protocol the receiver
should obtain sb so s sub b
so the security requirement is that the
receiver shouldn't learn
anything about the other string so s 1
minus b
so it should only learn the string that
it asked for
and similarly the sender should not
learn anything about the choice bit
b
so this is oblivious transfer and the
nice thing is that this simple
primitive is known to imply the full
mpc for any functionality and any
number of parties meaning that
if you can construct a protocol for
oblivious transfer
then you can also construct a protocol
for multi-party computation
and and this result has actually been
known for a while already
so we also know how to construct
oblivious terms of
from various computational assumptions
like learning with errors
diffie-hellman and others so in the
classical case
basically as a result we know npc from
all of these
assumptions which is which is great
however you know one of the general
goals of cryptography we can say is to
construct
primitives from the weakest possible
assumptions
and the existence of one-way functions
is pretty much the weakest
assumption that is known to be useful in
cryptography
so one-way function uh just to remind
you is simply a function that is easy to
compute but hard to invert on average
now we can build many nice things from
our functions like
pseudorandom generators commitments uh
secret key encryption
but crucially we know that one-way
functions do not
imply stronger primitives like public
key encryption
and in fact also they don't imply
oblivious transfer when they are used in
a black box
way so this is a result by impaliatsu
and rudige
and uh so using a one-way function in a
black box away means
not using its code but rather just
treating it like a black box
in in your protocol so there's this
black box separation in the classical
setting
but moreover we even don't really have
any candidates for
non-black box constructions of oblivious
transfer from one-way functions
so this is the um the situation in the
classical setting
uh i should also say that you know it
might seem
uh to some of you that we are kind of
splitting hairs here in
in the sense that we already have
constructions of oblivious transfer from
various assumptions
that we we believe to be true so why
should we care about constructing it
from our functions but the point is that
these assumptions are qualitatively
very different so diffie-hellman and
learning with errors these are
assumptions about the hardness of
particular
problems the existence of one-way
functions is much more generic
so we could in principle live in a world
which impalazzo calls minicrypt
in which one-way functions exist but
these other assumptions are false
and so what about in the quantum setting
so
in the quantum setting we again know
that oblivious transfer suffices for
multi-party computation
in fact a classical obedience transfer
suffices even for a multi-party
quantum computation meaning that the
parties and the adversaries could be
quantum
and they could be computing quantum
circuits on quantum inputs
but but now one surprising and sort of
exciting thing about the quantum world
is that we actually have a template
for building oblivious transfer uh which
uh
i guess from here onwards i will call uh
ot for short
so we have a template for building ot
from bit commitment
and i'll describe what a bit commitment
is soon
so this template crucially uses quantum
communication
and we have known about these templates
for a few decades already
it is from krapo and kilian and also
started by bennett brassard
[ __ ] and scubazevska now
uh unfortunately uh this is just a
template which
doesn't necessarily come with with
security proofs
um so it was later shown that this
template
can be instantiated using the learning
with errors
assumption although right this
implication here is something that we
already had
classically and so uh what about doing
things from
one-way functions so some of you might
know that the bit commitments
can be built from one-way functions and
in fact it turns out that instantiating
this template
from one-way functions with just plain
commitments
gives a weak version of ot
and so um without getting into sort of
how this version is weak
um in any case the this version this
week of t is not known
to be sufficient to get multi-party
computation
and so um prior to our work you know
this was the picture in the quantum
setting
and it was an open question whether the
standard or t
can be constructed from just um
from just one way functions
and so this work and the concurrent work
of grillo lean song and by
settle these questions by showing that
one-way functions indeed imply
ot and so they also imply a secure
multi-party computation in the quantum
setting
and so to put the classical and the
quantum picture side by side succinctly
in the classical world we have a black
box separation between one-way functions
and ot
and no plausible non-black box
constructions either
in the quantum world it was unclear
whether one was functions implied or t
and this is what our work in the
concurrent work resolved
so you know quantumly a world in which
one-way functions exist
is one in which we get you know even
multi-party
computation computation and this
implication here in fact
only makes black box use of the one-way
function
which is nice
good so so then in the rest of the talk
we will focus on constructing ot
from one way functions so before moving
on let me
first be slightly more precise about how
security
of oblivious transfer is defined so
recall what the functionality is the
sender has
two input strings s0 and s1
the receiver has as input a bit b they
exchange a number of
messages and at the end of their
interaction the receiver should get
sp so informally the security says that
the receiver shouldn't be learning
anything more than sb
um and the sender shouldn't learn
anything about
b about the choice b so more precisely
we can consider
security against a malicious receiver
who
deviates arbitrarily from the protocol
specifications
and at the end output some final state
are out which which you can think of as
you know what the malicious receiver has
learned
from all of this interaction and
security is formalized by saying that
for any malicious receiver there exists
a simulator which interacts with an
ideal
oblivious transfer functionality here in
the middle
so this is ideal in the sense that it
behaves exactly as it should
so think of it as a trusted third party
that gets the inputs from the two
parties in the protocol and implements
exactly the other
and the output of this simulator are out
should be computationally
indistinguishable from that of
the malicious receiver in the real
protocol
so this is sometimes referred to as the
real versus
ideal framework for security
so i'll parse this a bit more um slowly
so this so this definition basically uh
you know it's meant to capture the fact
that whatever the receiver can learn in
the real protocol
it could also have just as well learned
in an ideal protocol which is literally
ideal and
implemented by a trusted third party and
since the ideal protocol of course
doesn't reveal anything more than it
should then the malicious receiver
also doesn't learn anything in the real
protocol
and so yeah i understand that it takes a
moment to to get around this if it's the
first time that you hear
about this type of security so feel free
to ask if i can
you know clarify something
um yeah notice that actually this is a
quite strong or
restrictive notion of security in
particular since the simulator here is
interacting with the ideal
ot functionality just the syntax of this
definition
requires that the simulator extracts an
implicit choice bit b
from the receiver because it has to
provide some input
to the ideal functionality
and so in order to get this simulation
based security 40
the simula the simulator needs to be
able to extract inputs from the
malicious party
for example by interacting with it
internally
and so one thing to note is that here
the simulator has access to the internal
state
of the malicious receiver
and this access to the internal status
because we want to capture things that
the malicious receiver could learn on
its own in an ideal protocol
and we will see in fact that the
simulator having access to the internal
stability receiver will be
essential later
and then you know security against a
malicious sender is formalized in an
analogous way just with the roles
uh flipped okay
good um so i so we're now finally ready
to talk about this template
for ot using quantum communication this
is very similar to the bb-84 protocol
for key distribution so if you're
vaguely familiar with that then you
shouldn't have
any problem following this so in
particular this
template for ot starts in exactly the
same way
with the sender creating a bunch of
bb-84 states
so sampling a string of basis choices
either
computational or hadamard denoted by c
and h
and a string of encoded bits which we
will denote by x
so this x here specifies right whether
the state is zero or one
if in the computational basis and plus
or minus
if it's in the halomart and
then these states are sent over to the
receiver the receiver then much like in
the original the
bb84 protocol picks a uniformly random
string of basis choices theta prime and
then measures
uh in this theta prime basis and gets
some outcome
x prime now at this point the sender
reveals theta to the receiver
who can now sort of figure out which
qubits
were measured in the same in the right
basis so in the same basis as theta
so here they're denoted in green and
which ones it measured in the wrong
basis in a different basis and so the
key here is that you know for those
qubits that the receiver measured in the
right basis
it would have gotten outcomes that match
the string x exactly
whereas it would have gotten uniformly
random outcomes for the qubits
measured in the wrong in the different
bases
and um and the other uh crucial fact of
course is that the sender has
no way to know which qubits were
measured correctly and which were not
because
theta prime is not being revealed here
and now you know what the receiver does
is it partitions the indices into two
subsets i0 and a1 in particular it will
set
i uh b so i sub b where b is
the receiver's choice bit to be the
subset of indices on which
theta matches theta prime so the indices
that are in green
here um and it will set the other
subset i 1 minus b to be you know the
set of indices on which the basis does
not
match
and this the receiver then communicates
i zero and a one
and you know crucially the sender here
does not know which set contains
the matching the indices for the
matching basis
uh the sender will similarly partition
the string x into
two parts according to the sets i zero
and a one and so uh you know x0 sorry
x0 will be the string uh the substring
within this is in i0
x1 will be the substring within this is
in i1
and and sort of the last step is that
the sender uses this
uh substring x0 to encrypt
the first input string s0
and then it uses x1 to encrypt s1
where here by encryption i just mean
something information theoretically
hiding
like for example applying a universal
hash function
to x0 using this just as a one-time pad
to hide as zero if these are not terms
that are familiar to you just
you know just know that this encryption
step is information theoretic
um and these two encryptions are both
sent to the receiver
and uh you know finally the receiver
knows xb
it knows one of the two sub strings the
one
corresponding to the subset in which it
it measured
in the subset of indices in which it had
matching bases
and it can use xb to decrypt and get the
string as b
and so if the parties are honest here
this realizes our ot
functionality
and now um sort of what is the intuition
for security right
so the sender the sender has no clue
about the bit b because the two sets i
zero and i one here that it receives are
distributed identically
theta prime is sampled uniformly at
random it's never revealed
so the sender doesn't know on which
indices
the two parties had matching basis on
the other hand
for security against a malicious
receiver notice that the receiver
will have measured in a matching basis
at only about half
of the locations and so at least one of
the two substrings
x0 or x1 should have high entropy
from from its point of view and so the
receiver will only be able to decrypt
at most one of the two messages
which gives us ot and so are we are we
done then
uh well no in fact we are uh far from it
still
so the issue here um is that um
it's an issue that you might have heard
about before
the issues that the malicious receiver
need not perform
the measurement as prescribed and
instead it can just delay the
measurement until after
it gets theta but then
you know of course at that point once it
knows theta
it can measure in the theta basis and
recover the whole
string x so the receiver will know both
x0 it will know x1
and it will be able to obtain both of
the two
messages as 0 and x and s0 and s1 which
which breaks the security of ot
so so we definitely need to do something
to fix this so you know we need to
force the receiver to measure at the
right time
and we can do this by using a commitment
so let me have a very very brief
excursion
to sort of tell you what the commitment
is
so um right a commitment you can think
of as
the cryptographic way of implementing a
locked box
so here we have a committer on the left
um
so the committer can commit to a bit b
by putting it inside a locked
box and sending this to the receiver
and so uh the first property satisfied
by the commitment is that it should be
hiding so meaning that the receiver
shouldn't learn anything
about the b2b by just looking at the box
now at a later time we would like the
committer to be able to reveal
what it committed to by by sending some
key
that allows the receiver to open the box
and we want this commitment to be also
binding
in the sense of the committer shouldn't
be able to change its mind
on what it committed to so there should
be no way for the committer
to open anything other than b
so these are the the two basic
properties that
that one requires usually of a bit
commitment
now note that you know the commit part
here is depicted
as a single message but it can actually
also be interactive and
in fact it will be interactive for us as
we will see
later and so um
now we can use a bit commitment to
enforce that the receiver measures when
it's supposed to and so the uh the first
part of the protocol
will be the same as before so the
receiver creates and sends a bunch of
bb-84 states to the receiver
we ask the receiver to pick basis theta
prime measure
in this basis and now the only thing
that we do
different is we add the following
measurement
check sub protocol so for each qubit we
ask the receiver
to send a commitment to the the
measurement basis choices and
and the outcomes obtained and the idea
is now that the sender will test
the committed values are legitimate they
are consistent
and the sender will do this by picking a
uniformly random subset of locations to
test
for example here um qubits two and four
and it will ask the receiver to provide
the keys to open the boxes two and four
um and and once it receives the keys for
four two and four oh i don't know what
happened there
um it opens the uh the commitments
uh and it and it checks whether uh the
reported bases match
uh with tita so whether the outcomes
match
with uh with x
and so in these cases so in this case
the basis was different for qubit 2
but it was the same for 4 and so
the sender checks that the outcomes are
the same in this case they are
so we call this a sub-protocol the
measurement check subprotocol
and the rest of the protocol is then the
same as before you know the sender sends
theta
um the receiver partitions
in the indices into two strings a0 and
i1
where ib will contain all of the indices
where the bases match
sends i 0 and i1 then the sender
encrypts
using x0 and x1 and finally
the receiver can decrypt using
whichever substring it knows
and you know the intuition for security
here is that if this protocol is
executed with large number of qubits
and as long as the sender tests a large
enough number of commitments
then you know if a receiver passes the
measurement check protocol
it really must have measured
right and so one of the two sub strings
0 or x1 must have a lot of entropy from
its point of view
so this commitment is just forcing a
measurement
and so you know then do commitments
imply
then and you know by the way as i
mentioned it is known that uh basic
commitments can be built just from
one-way functions
so then you know does this mean that we
are done at this point
and uh you know the answer is not quite
because proving
the kind of security that we want is a
bit more subtle
so recall how we we define security
so we say that you know for any
malicious receiver in the protocol
there should be a simulator which
interacts only with the ideal ot
functionality
and outputs a computationally
indistinguishable output
so in other words you know anything that
a malicious receiver can learn in the
real protocol
can also be learned by interacting with
this ideology
and now also recall the observation that
we made earlier which is that the
simulator
just syntactically has to provide
a b2b to the ideal functionality
so it has to be able to extract an
implicit choice bit b from the receiver
you know in particular just to get a
better idea
of what this type of security is saying
you know you can consider a special case
of a receiver that behaves as an
honest receiver with input b well then
you know this receiver will
obtain eventually as b at the end of the
real protocol
and so the simulator must be able to
extract b
in order to obtain sb as well from the
ideal
ot functionality there is no other way
right for the simulator to get sb
and so uh you know just to make things
more concrete the process on the top
looks like this right we have a
malicious receiver interacting in any
way it wants in the real
protocol as long as it respects the
syntax of the protocol
and at the end outputting some
information which you can think of as
what it has learned from the interaction
and then we have the ideal process which
has to simulate the same distribution of
this
output are out at the bottom by
interacting with the ideal
ot and in particular here the simulator
can
depend on the malicious receiver it can
for instance
interact with it internally right by
running a simulated
version of the real protocol for example
if it so wishes
so for example it could give bb-84
states internally to to the receiver get
back some commitments around the
measurement check protocol
reveal theta and get some subsets of
indices
i zero and i1
however you know note that the the
commitments that the simulator has
obtained here
internally are supposed to be hiding
and so it's not quite clear how the
simulator can ever succeed
at finding out b which uh here would be
equivalent to finding out
which of i zero and i one contains the
indices
for for the matching bases
and and you know in fact if you think
about it uh
notice that it shouldn't be possible to
learn the choice bit b
just by interacting with r because
otherwise
the sender could also do exactly the
same thing and learn b
and this of course would not be secure
so then you know what gives and
the crucial part is that here the
simulator has access to r's internal
state
so it can do things like for example
rewinding
the malicious receiver and so for a
simulator that has
access to the internal state of the
receiver all bets are off
when it comes to the hiding property of
the commitment
and it's at least in principle possible
that the simulator may be able to
violate
this hiding property and find out the
committed
values so open this these boxes
and now um this property of being able
to extract
a committed value when given access to
the internal state of the committer
it can be formalized and it is a
stronger property than the basic
requirement of hiding and binding and we
will talk about this this property which
is called
extractability in in just a moment
and so it turns out the that you know
this ot template can be proven secure
when instantiated with a commitment
which satisfies
certain stronger properties so one is
precisely
extractability and the other is called
equivocality which we will see also next
so the moral of the story so far is that
there there is this template for a tea
from bb-84 states
which uses commitments uh however plane
commitments
don't seem to to suffice and this is
because the simulation based
security notion requires us to extract
an implicit input from the malicious
party
[Music]
and the ot template can be shown to be
sound however when the commitment
satisfies
these two stronger properties here
and so let's start from extractable
commitments which we have already
mentioned a moment ago
so a commitment is extractable if on top
of satisfying the basic hiding and
binding
it also satisfies the following there
exists
an efficient extractor x here in blue
which has access to the internal state
of the committer
and is able to extract the implicit
committed bit b
so again you can think of this as being
able to violate the high adding property
when you're given access to the internal
state of the committee
now what about equivocal commitments so
this on the other hand you can think of
as being able to violate the binding
property of the commitment when you have
access to the internal state of the
receiver
so uh in an equivocal commitment there
is an alternative way
to commit i think of this as an
equivocal
mode and there is an equivocator here
that is capable in the opening phase of
opening this this previous commitment to
any value at once
so and the value could be chosen after
the the commitment phase so it breaks
the binding property
but only when you have access to the
internal state of the receiver
and so let's see these two new
properties of commitment in action
how they help us uh prove security of
our ot template
so uh given a malicious receiver in the
ot protocol
a simulator can interact with it by
playing the part of the
of the sender and it can obtain
commitments
and two subsets of indices a0 and a1
just like we saw before
it can then leverage the fact that the
commitment is
extractable in order to open those
commitments
and figure out which of the two sets uh
zero and a one contains
the the bases that are matching the
indices for the bases that are matching
and from this it can just infer the
choice bit b so that's how
the simulator extract the choice
extracts the choice bit b
and similarly in order to prove security
against a malicious sender
the simulator has to be able to extract
the input strings at
0 and s1 and we will leverage the
equivocal
property here too of the commitment for
this
so um i will give myself a little bit
more space to show you
you know how the simulator acts
interacts internally
with with the sender to extract the two
inputs
so uh the simulator here on the right
and this is sort of all happening inside
the simulator
the simulator would run the whole ot
protocol playing the part
of the receiver except that it
commits using the equivocal mode of the
commitment
so this means that it can make up its
mind later about the committed values
so it doesn't have to measure right away
it first waits
to receive the subset of qubit locations
that are tested and only measures
those particular locations and it can
uh open the tested commitments to the
appropriate values
sort of after the fact by by leveraging
equivocality
and then once it receives theta it
measures the remaining qubits in the
correct basis and is able to recover
both s0 and ns1
so so this is how the simulator extracts
the sender's inputs
and so you know i realized that there
are a few moving pieces and
and all of this so in case you you kind
of zone out a little bit
um here is a recap of what we have
discussed so far
so we have seen that there is um a
template for ot from commitments
um and that this template is secure
where security means satisfying the
simulation-based type security
when it is instantiated using a stronger
kind of commitment that is
both extractable and equivocal
and so the question now is can we build
such
a commitment
and so our result is that we construct a
commitment that is both
extractable and equivocal from black box
use
of one-way functions and
given what we have discussed so far you
know the the consequence of this
is that oblivious transfer can be built
from one way functions
and so crucially we give a quantum
construction of the commitment
i think that previously people may have
tried to construct such an extractable
uh inequitable commitment without
success uh classically
but here the interaction in the
commitment itself
will involve quantum communication so
not only does the ot template already
involve quantum communication for
sending the bb-84 states
but the commitment itself will require
quantum communication
and there are two new building blocks
that we develop in order to achieve all
of this
the first is an equivocality compiler
meaning
a transformation that turns any plane
uh commitment into an equivocal one
and the second building block is a
transformation that turns any equivocal
commitment into
an extractable commitment so it starts
from an equivocal one and what you get
out
is extractable but not necessarily
equivocal
and you can put together these two new
building blocks in the following way
you know you can start from a plane
commitment which can be built from just
one wave functions
and using a construction of of an hour
uh
we can then apply the equivalent so the
building block number one the
equivocality compiler
to obtain an equivocal commitment
and then we can apply this equivocal to
extractable
transformation to obtain something that
is extractable but not necessarily
equivocal and finally if we apply
the first building block again
to turn the letter into something that
is both extractable
and equivocal at the same time
so this is a bit of a winding path
and the only thing to make sure for for
the last step is that
this equivocality compiler preserves
extractability
which which it does
now the the equivalent compiler is a bit
technical but not necessarily so
insightful
on the other hand the transformation
from equivocal to extractable
so this middle step here i find quite
interesting
because it reveals some kind of duality
between equivocality and extractability
and this is also the step that involves
quantum communication
so so maybe um let me just
in a couple minutes um i don't know how
how we're doing
on time um i can
so you have uh something like eight
minutes including questions
okay so let me spend just a couple of
minutes to give you the idea for this
uh so the idea for this starts out by
noticing that the
ot template from [ __ ] and kilian
can be modified just slightly to obtain
a template for commitments so this is
even easier than
getting ot it's a very simple template
we have on the left a committer who
wants to commit to a bit b
and on the right a receiver for the
commitment
and now the committer starts again by
preparing a bunch of bb-84 states and
sending them to the receiver
and then the receiver picks uh basis
theta prime and measures in this basis
so
so far this is just like a bb-84 just
like the ot template
and now at this point the committer just
simply reveals
in order to commit it reveals theta and
sends over
an encryption of the bit b using x
as the encryption key so this is the the
commit
phase it's very simple and the core idea
is the same as for the
ot template so basically notice that
because the receiver has measured in the
basis theta prime it has destroyed
the information about x on about half of
the locations
and so this encryption should be hiding
because the receiver
doesn't know say half of x and now in
order to open
the committed bit b the committer simply
stands over
x and the receiver just checks that
x matches x prime on the locations where
they measured in the same basis and if
this check passes the receiver is happy
and uses x to decrypt and recover b
and so informally this commitment is
binding because even though the receiver
has only recovered about half of the
string x
the sender does not know which bits of x
this are so the committer cannot really
lie
about x now uh
the issue here of course is the same as
as we face in the ot template
which is the receiver could delay the
measurement until after
it receives theta and break the hiding
property in this case
and so we can again try to fix this with
the measurement checksub protocol
asking the receiver to commit to the
basis and measurement outcomes
but you know here there is an issue we
are trying to build
a commitment so we can't use a
commitment in the measurement check
protocol itself
so the point is we will use an equivocal
commitment in the measurement check
protocol
and what we will eventually obtain is an
extractable
commitment and seeing that the resulting
commitment is extractable is
very similar to how we showed that we
could get the inputs from a malicious ot
sender
so the extractor here would just commit
using the equivocal
mode uh and use this to delay
the measurement until after it sees uh
where it's being tested um
okay so uh just to conclude i mean one
thing that it's easy to miss
um basically
notice that once we plug our newly
constructed commitment into the final
ot the protocol will have both parties
sending bb-84 states to each other
which i find uh quite interesting so
basically the protocol will look like
this
we have the the sender in the ot sending
the bb-84 states
the receiver committing but as we just
saw
you know the extractable commitment here
will involve the receiver also sending
bb-84 states and so in the end we have
both parties sending bb-84 states to
each other
which is a bit unusual
okay i will stop here in case there are
questions
thank you so thank you very much yeah
further questions